TWO TEAMS THAT MET IN THE
SECOND ROUND OF THE STANLEY CUP
PLAYOFFS IN A SEAREA SHE'S
DESPERATE TO BUY FORDSEASON. AN
POST AT A ROCK IS TO THE CORNER
PALAT HANGING ONTO THE PUCK AND
SWEEPS IT  FROMBECAUSE SOMETHIN
HAPPENED TO THE BLADE.
IT
HIS MAN OFF THE PUCK BACK DEEP
FOR  STAMKOS
WORKING TOGETHER AND TO PICK
PLAYED BY KILLORN THAT WORKED
OUT WELL ANDYED AGAIN ON
THURSDAY ALL BEF MARTINOOK
COMING FOR A PIECE OF HIM.
ANYTHINGN MOVE IN AND HE
DOES DRIVING
VASILEVSKIY WANTS A PIECE OF
THAT AS WELL AND HAS BEEN DOING
TOP WINE.
ITSVECHNIKOV
FRUSTRATED.  CORNER HE PUTS IT
INTO THEYOU THINK YOU ARE IN
TROUBLE IF YOU ARE CAROLINA
DEFENSIVELY AND ALL OF A
GETS THE PUCK
RESETS. HERE
WILLIAM NEE LANDER WITH A 4-3 N
BEING
CHECK.
TROCHECK
BOUNCES RIGHT TO AHO.
OVER